it is 5 24 on your friday morning
remember a few weeks ago i told you who
won this year's mojave max emergence
contest now it's time to show you their
field trip to the springs preserve
the fourth graders from miss bowker's
class at hinman elementary in henderson
were greeted by the mojave max mascot
contest winner riley and her classmates
then took a train ride around 180 acre
property learning some of the history of
the las vegas valley
then it was time to meet the real desert
tortoise who lives at the springs
preserve with dozens of other
critters are food water
and shelter plenty of ooze in us as the
17 year old tortoise casually wandered
around a classroom apparently wasn't
really interested in the flowers that
had been laid out for him but the
students were really interested in
munching down on some pizza
a representative from commissioner jim
gibson's office presented riley with her
certificate before donovan gusman from
get outdoors nevada presented the grand
prizes
yeah there's one computer for riley and
one for the teacher miss bowker thanks
to the springs preserve clark county
desert conservation program get outdoors
nevada coordinator shelly kapinski can't
wait for next year to start the mojave
max school assemblies and emergence
contest all over again you know
something that's cool at school let us
know cool it's cool under the community
tab at 8 news now dot com or email cool
at school eight news now dot com